hey guys it's Jonah here the summer
holidays are over so it's back to work
off school well it is my favorite month
so let's start this season full of
energy connect with positive people and
spread good vibes how I do it is being
part of the pump up family this positive
community is spice you to it well stay
active and love yourself from the inside
and out so on certain days when you
might feel a little bit down or
demotivated scrolling through and
reading those positive posts will help
you to get back on track with the
routine download the app if you haven't
yet done it and follow me at Joanna so I
promise you you will love it so this
month I want you to get excited over
your meals I'm going to share with you
three really fun lunchbox
recipes which are delicious nutritious
and can be made ahead I get to work or
school and share these yummy bites with
your friends well I'm already excited so
let's start cooking
I love baked chicken kabob skewers
that's because you get a dip and bite
into a little bit of everything it's a
really fun way to add variety and enjoy
baked chicken and vegetables on a stick
the ingredients you'll need are three
and a half ounces of chicken breasts
diced into cubes 1 medium yellow bell
pepper diced into cubes 1 cup of
zucchini diced into cubes and half a cup
of cherry tomatoes to make the marinade
mixture you'll need juice from 1 lemon
1/2 a tbsp of olive oil 1/2 a tbsp of
garlic powder and salt and pepper to
taste the first crucial step is to soak
the bamboo skewers in water for at least
15 minutes to prevent them from burning
in the oven in a small bowl combine
lemon juice olive oil garlic powder and
salt and pepper set aside in a large
bowl combine chicken cubes bell pepper
zucchinis cherry tomatoes and marinade
mixture mix until evenly coated allow
the meat and vegetables to marry
for at least twenty to thirty minutes to
keep the meat tender and to enhance the
flavor preheat the oven to 190 degrees
Celsius or 375 degrees Fahrenheit while
waiting for the meats and vegetables to
marinate let's go ahead and make the
Greek yogurt ranch dip to go along with
the skewers in a bowl combine 1/2 a cup
of Greek yogurt with 1/8 teaspoon of
garlic powder dried chives dried parsley
and cane pepper
each season with salt and pepper set
aside thread the marinated meat and
vegetables onto the soaked wooden
skewers and place onto a baking tray
this would make about eight to ten short
skewers bake in the oven for 15 minutes
turn over once and continue baking for
another 15 minutes until chicken is
cooked through remove from oven and
allow the chicken skewers to cool down
I'll pack my chicken kabob skewers with
quarter cup of the Rancher did served
with quarter cup of Olives you have to
dip the skewer into the yogurt ranch
dressing it is so flavorsome this is a
great way to add colorful vegetables
into your diet and avoid overeating and
when you have eight to ten skewers for
lunch
trust me you will be satisfied another
really fun idea is to turn the boring
sandwiches into mini sushi rolls or
students if you can't cook this is the
perfect recipe for you absolutely no
cooking is required and you can assemble
them in less than five minutes sweet or
savory I can't decide so let's make both
the ingredients you need are two medium
bread slices one turkey or chicken
breast slice half a tablespoon of cream
cheese zucchini carrot and bell pepper
sticks 1/2 a tablespoon of peanut butter
and 1 small banana start by cutting the
crusts off on all sides of two breads
then use a rolling pin to really flatten
the bread
thin as possible put some energy into it
on one bread spread a thin layer of
cream cheese top with Turkey slice
zucchini carrot and bell pepper sticks
firmly roll the mixture up and press to
seal into a roll on another flattened
bread spread thin layer of peanut butter
and place banana at one end of the bread
roll it up firmly finally cut each roll
into four even pieces now let's put your
chopsticks skill into test eat this
sandwich sushi rolls with chopsticks
instead so what I love about this is
that because you're taking smaller bites
it makes you think and feel like you're
eating more I'll pack them with the
extra chopped up vegetable sticks soft
with quarter cup of ranch dip from the
previous recipe they are so fun to look
at and eat your friends would definitely
want to steal some let me know in the
comments below and finally egg muffins
for lunch I have previously shed this
recipe in my make-ahead breakfast video
but these egg muffins are also great as
a lunch to go they are high in protein
packed with vegetables and so convenient
to eat what you'll need are four large
eggs 1/2 a cup of mushrooms finely diced
1/2 a cup of carrots finely diced cut a
cup of whole Khans could cut a cup of
cherry tomatoes 1/2 cut a cup of bell
pepper finely diced 1 TSP of olive oil 1
tablespoon of grated cheese and salt and
pepper to taste
previous the oven to 180 degrees Celsius
or 350 degrees Fahrenheit in a large
bowl combine in mushrooms carrots cones
cherry tomatoes bell pepper with olive
oil mix well equally distribute the
vegetable mixture into each muffin
cavity and set aside crack four eggs
into a bowl and lightly beat with a
whisk add salt and pepper
taste and whisk to combine pour the
beaten egg equally into each cavity top
with a little bit of grated cheese then
bake in the oven for 20 minutes or until
muffins are set eggs are cooked through
and unlikely golden allow the muffins to
cool down for about 10 minutes
I'll pack three mushroom egg muffins
into my lunchbox with 1 cup of fruit
mixture and quarter cup of Greek yogurt
this egg muffins are so delicious and
each one is only seventy eight point
five calories you have to try them all
these recipes can be eaten both warm and
chilled they can be stored in the fridge
for up to three days so this makes it
very convenient for you to prep your
lunches ahead what I love about this
recipes is that once you get a basic
idea you can repeat the recipe with
different ingredients so that you won't
be bored eating the same lunch box over
and over again for instance you can
choose other meat and vegetables for the
kabob skewers you can make different
sweet and savory fillings for the
sandwiches sushi rolls and same goes to
the egg muffins you can add any
vegetables and even need for the muffin
feelings so I hope this fun simple
delicious and healthy recipes will get
you excited about lunch make them share
them with your friends snap and post a
picture tap me and let me know which is
a favorite in the comments below all the
best
you